WANDA MAXIMOFF
We are an unusual couple.
ELIZABETH OLSEN
It was really so fun getting to play
all these different
decades throughout WandaVision.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
We just don't know what to expect.
PAUL BETTANY
And then of course, everything kind of
breaks down and becomes
an MCU version of the real world.
AGNES
[Gasps] Am I dead?
VISION
No!
Why would you think that?
AGNES
Because you are.
KATHRYN HAHN
I can't believe how it just keeps
unraveling and unfolding in ways
that I am still shocked and thrilled by.
JIMMY WOO
Wanda, can you read me?
MATT SHAKMAN
Everyday it's something different.
You know, it's high-tech
Marvel with helicopters flying around,
and the next day it's a
perfect recreation of a 50s sitcom.
You know, some days it's both.
VISION
I think something's wrong here.
PAUL BETTANY
I think it's gonna be really satisfying
for people when they realize
what is at the heart of this show.
WANDA MAXIMOFF
This is our home.
VISION
Then let's fight for it.